Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Most of you probably saw the announcement
this past week
that Marvel is actually working on Thor
five without Taika Waititi.
He won't be involved anymore
And because we're in the middle of Loki season 2
episodes right now, the Loki producers
have also revealed that the plan
is to eventually reunite Thor and Loki,
confirming a lot of your fan theories.
Loki has also been referencing Thor
a lot this season so far.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
And we're doing that.
Give away for the Spider-Man two game.
All you have to do to Enter is be a subscriber
and just let me know
how you want them to actually reunite
on screen.
Thor and Loki.
real quick reminder too.
There's like a weird spam bot
pretending to be me going through comments,
replying to people about fake giveaways.
that is not me.
But I think a lot of you have figured that out.
So be careful.
but earlier this year we heard
Marvel was going to do Thor five at some point
there were a bunch of comments from Taika
Waititi and Chris Hemsworth separately
revealing some of the plans
for the future of the Thor character.
but the real big change recently
is that it seems like Taika Waititi is out.
He's no longer part of the project.
So if you hated Thor, Love and Thunder,
this is good news for you.
but. Taika did reveal some of the plans
for the future of the Thor character.
What the trains are reporting is Taika
Waititi talking about what they would do
after Thor, Love and Thunder.
And this is his quote.
He says, What's left to do with him
talking about Thor himself
It's got to be something else that feels like
it's carrying on with the evolution
of the character, but still in a very fun way
and still giving him things to come up against
that feel like they're building on obstacles
that he has to overcome.
I don't think we can have a villain
that's weaker than HeLa.
I feel like
we need to have a step up from there
and add a villain
that's somehow more formidable.
I think that even though Taika
is off the movie, apparently his comments
about the future Thor will still hold true
just in general.
they've already set up this arc with Hercules
and the gods going after Thor
trying to kill him.
I'll explain that in a second.
that might wind up being a completely separate
thing because Taika Waititi
was talking about that recently, saying that
he wasn't going to be involved with that.
we can introduce Hercules
and let's make love this notion of it.
But apparently it is, and
it is.
And I know it's opening up a whole new thing,
which I love,
but I think maybe for everyone who loves Greek
gods.
Talking more about the lead up
into the next Avengers movies.
That's sort of the beginning of this Kang
Multiverse, new Avengers stuff,
all coming together in a clear way.
Marvel Phase five is sort of like the march
as they bring them all slowly together
by the end of Marvel. Phase five,
the beginning of Marvel, Phase six.
There is a version of the New Avengers team
that'll start to happen in Captain America
four New World Order.
Like the Falcon, Captain America will slowly
start putting his quote unquote team together.
And that is the new Avengers team.
and currently right now, Thor is one of the few
remaining original core Avengers
I just did a bunch of Captain America
for New World Order in Thunderbolts videos
because there's a big World War Hulk plot,
Big Hulk related plot that's flying
through those with Red Hulk, with Bruce
Banner's Hulk in with Scar, Son of Old.
just in terms of Chris Hemsworth's character.
We last saw him at the end of Thor, Love
and Thunder end, at the end of that movie
he agreed to raise Gorge resurrected.
Now Super child named Love
resurrected by eternity, the child of eternity.
That's where her superpowers came from.
and they just go on adventures
together around the universe,
helping people giving the movie its title.
They are both love and thunder, going around
helping people.
here's where we start
to get to The plot of the next door movie.
Like Love will not be a big character in that.
But when the events of the movie pick up,
Thor will still be doing what he's doing now,
going around helping people,
The Jane Foster stuff, Sacrificing herself
and then going to Valhalla when she dies
is also meant to be more of an Avengers
six Secret Wars teaser.
Eventually, she will come back, per
the rules they set up in Moonlight.
I think the reason she ended up there is
because she formed a contract with the Hammer.
Like even though Moon Knight himself
did not believe in the Egyptian afterlife,
he formed a contract with Concho
to become Moon Knight.
And that's why he wound up in the duel
and as far as I know she heimdall
the original Loki from the 616 Marvel universe
not coming back during Thor five.
It's always possible, But I think it's meant
to be more of a secret Wars teaser
and eventually we will see versions of them
slowly cameo in other future movies.
some of them won't come back permanently.
Some of them will just be cameos.
But that's the whole reason
why they tease Valhalla
in another dimension, like,
Oh, they're all still here.
They can come back to the main MCU
dimension eventually.
now, when the Loki season
two producers said that Marvel
is planning on reuniting Thor and Loki,
I think they were referencing
the current version of Loki
that we're watching on the Loki series.
Like the variant who's at the TVA.
so the original Loki could still come back.
But I think creatively Marvel just focusing
all their attention on reuniting Thor
with this new version of Loki
and how that would complicate their reunion.
Think about it this way.
Even though we've been seeing this
Loki and Marvel phase for Marvel Phase five, he
basically skipped over a bunch of Marvel movies
much earlier in the timeline.
so he went through a totally different
character arc than the original Loki.
So his relationship with the main
Thor would probably be a little bit different,
You have to imagine Thor's eyes glazing over,
though in confusion when Loki tries to explain
time travel the TVA to him.
Everything that's happened
with all the Kang variants The Hercules
Post-Credits scene is really
just about setting up the next Thor movie.
Not so much about Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty or Avengers six Secret Words,
but Hercules might also appear
in secret words in a cameo to
Because every
character in the history of Marvel is supposed
to have some kind of cameo in that movie.
Like think the portal scene from Avengers
Endgame times 100.
You want more?
Yes. Yes, we wanted more.
Bring every single character ever.
even Howard The Duck was in the portal scene
in Avengers Endgame.
So if Howard the Duck made it
into the first version of that,
you have to imagine
the most obscure of characters
will probably make it
into the secret wards version of that.
but when Zus tells Hercules to go kill Thor
and creates this larger plan
to make the lesser beings
normal people fear the gods again,
because the whole theme in the movie is
that people have turned away from the gods.
they also address that during moonlight
as well.
way fewer people across the universe
believe in gods.
So was a way to make the people fear them
again.
Zus is having Hercules
kill Thor in broad daylight, so to speak,
it is more of a Thor versus
all the other Gods kind of movie,
like a War of Realms type of conflict,
a mini version of Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers Endgame,
where it's all about Thor versus
the rest of the gods,
which is kind of funny
because that's kind of what they said.
Thor Love and Thunder up to be like Gore versus
all of the other gods during that movie
Thor even jokes about how all the other gods
are going to hate them
and want to kill them now.
Now they're just paying that off like,
oh, yeah,
they're definitely coming to try and kill you
In the comics, Hercules was meant
to be about as powerful as Thor,
just like Thor in the comics too.
He also gained greater
cosmic levels of power to become God of Gods
Rune King Thor is a good example of that,
like Thor becoming the God of all Gods.
That's how powerful he was during Chaos War.
More recently in the comics, Hercules
also became God of all Gods.
so even though their powers work
very differently,
they're kind of the same power level,
basically.
even if you haven't read a lot of Hercules
comics in the past, MCU Hercules
powers are similar to a lot of the other pop
culture depictions of Hercules.
He starts out as a demigod,
a son of Zeus and a human woman,
and throughout his adventures
attains more power and eventually has to choose
whether to live the rest of his existence
as a full on God, like hundred percent God
or pull of Thor
in Avengers Endgame and just continue
having adventures on his own on ground level.
Thor's arc in
the MCU has been pretty much that.
Like, do you accept your responsibility
to become king of your people,
become more of an actual God to your people,
or do you just continue
having fun across the universe
since Chris Hemsworth is saying that that next
Thor movie versus Hercules in the Gods
is meant to be his last time as the character.
Most people think that means that Hercules
is going to be
successful in killing him, but I don't think
that that's what they're going with.
also, I think the Chris Hemsworth
is being a little misleading
when he's saying he's leaving the character
like Hugh Jackman left Wolverine after Logan.
Patrick Stewart
also left Professor X after Logan.
But here they are
playing their characters again a lot.
Deadpool three is like a full on Deadpool
and Wolverine movie.
end, by the end of his last movie,
he will accept the greater cosmic role
and become a little bit more like Rune
King Thor in the way he fit within
the Marvel Universe in more of a God of Gods
cosmic kind of role in.
That'll be how they explain
why Thor isn't around day to day
all the time for regular movies anymore,
but how he can still come back for cameos
occasionally in the future
when they really want him.
a lot of the plot of Qing Dynasty
is based on Avengers Kang War in the comics,
which is a little bit different.
But a lot of the new Avengers
team in Kang War is the Avengers team
that we're going to see in the MCU.
we also have gotten Spider-Man
four before that happens.
So I know there's lots of questions
about what the spell changed with Spider-Man
and The Avengers.
It didn't change him fighting with The Avengers
or being on the Avengers team.
They just forgot that Peter Parker
is the person underneath Spider-Man's mask.
the only other really cool fan favorite
slam dunk characters
you could put him up against that
people will get really hyped about
would be, say, like Galactus,
like Thor versus Galactus
or Thor versus Silver Surfer is a character
that they have introduced yet,
and we know the Silver Surfer isn't supposed
to be in the next Fantastic Four movie.
My Full Loki Season 2 Episode
5 Video will post later this week,
so be sure to enable alerts
so you don't miss that.
I'm not expecting a Thor cameo
in the last two episodes of Loki,
but there might be some more Thor references.
bigger reminder that Invincible Season 2
episodes are also starting this week.
Congratulations, Crunchy Frog 1709 You're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
everyone click here for my Loki Season
2 Episode 5 Video
and click here for my full Loki Season
2 Episode 4 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!